[Music]
you know the old adage never work with
kids or animals
anyway i worked with a dog uh named
speaking of
look i don't want to say anything
negative because actually the trainer
was really sweet the whole family was
nice and and what they were asking this
dog to do was really difficult i played
a guy who whose best friend was a dog
and so he was going with me everywhere
and here's his name's polo and polo just
he rides next to me and he walks with me
and we do everything together and so it
really had to be like on me and it
didn't know me and i you know how i am
with things that i find cute i get a
little
eager
and i and i think i got a little eager
with shiloh with shiloh was his name i
just outed him
um adorable dog he's gonna be
embarrassed to hear the story yes
i put him on instagram um but he is um
he was supposed to
for example he was supposed to lick the
face of one of the actors who was
playing alex moffatt very funny alex
hopefully future uh guess the show he
was supposed to lick his face and alex
is playing kind of a douchey guy who
doesn't like animals and he's supposed
to ugh what are you doing and um
how many times have you been around a
dog that has unsolicited
italy licked your face many times yes
and you're not crazy about it i know but
um this dot this shadow wouldn't it
wouldn't go near his face and the
trainer had these little bits of ham in
her pocket that she was luring luring
the dog with uh and coked like tempting
him with and
alex moffatt had to good ol alex like
what a what a pro
put a piece of the pocket ham in his his
mouth
my stomach just turned to get to get
pocket ham is one of the grossest
two words i've ever heard about to get
together shiloh to lick his mouth and
and uh he finally did he got it and when
we got the scene it was great and here's
the irony is that um as difficult as it
was to work with this animal
it's gonna be the star of the [ __ ] the
show it's gonna be
i said to the director like even if we
get terrible reviews shiloh's gonna get
glowing reviews he's gonna win an oscar
someday yes and it was adorable and i'm
really happy to have had the experience
and so uh happy ending yeah it was it
was and i hope you're happy for
a podcast experience that hopefully will
also happen i don't have to do that i
know i'd like to tie things together
here we go
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life for sure i am
your animal loving host by the way it's
fair to say yeah
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always
christian my brother your animal
tolerating yes brother you tolerate
animals really well yeah thank you what
is what if you were to get an animal
what would it be
a bunny yeah i like bunnies do you
answer that so fast i gave me saderas i
like bunnies uh i like amy sedaris yeah
okay there you go well um speaking of
why are we talking about
well also animals yeah and um so is it
is it safe to say that a dog you worked
with
would you describe that dog as a bit
clueless i mean can you describe a dog's
clothes um i i guess so i don't know i
don't think that's fair to the dogs
about the dog trainer
no they were they had a clue they i
think they're really good trainers i
just think it's
what this dog had to do and it was short
notice it was one of those movies that
like came together quickly so for our
purposes let's call this dog clueless i
would say okay for the purposes of what
it had to do in the movie it didn't have
much of a clue and for the purpose of
the pivot we need to make yes yes that's
true even more important i guess and
speaking of being clueless
and animals our guest today
was the star of the seminal
teen movie that classic easy to say you
know some movies you're like exactly you
have to you have to ask yourself yes was
it would this be considered a class
dances with wolves at classic you don't
have to ask that question no classic
classic clueless classic iconic for the
ages and our guest today is what's the
star of that movie and so many other
great movies and so many other great
things what's her name her name thank
you for asking
it's alicia silverstone do you say
alicia or alicia oh it's alicia otis
what did i say alicia i thought you said
alicia
i did
alicia i think it's alicia i think so
too i know her a little bit but um
never like i said where i've never had
occasion to to nerd out on her and um
i've there was a lot of nerding out that
i that i was capable of with her because
yeah like you said i've known her i've
known of her i've been such a fan of her
since since clueless since actually
before
god i remember um
those videos iconic videos the aerosmith
videos twinkle in your eyes recall these
well she was a big part of my my
upbringing i i just had such a she was
in the crush i had a huge crush on her i
think everyone did everyone did she was
like the prettiest yeah and she still is
god she looks
of course but as a kid
you're coming of age you're you're that
yeah when clueless came out you were 16
years old we were the same age i mean
that's i know almost been in love with
her
it was and i didn't want to like dwell
on that and i don't want to dwell on it
now because um because she she really is
such an impressive person and she what
she's doing is i think
just so good for the world um
and i know she's been
in the news oftentimes like you know the
way the news picks up on just a little
portion of what somebody is doing just
just something that they can make
salacious and and uh scandalous whatever
um and they and they did that i think
with her i think very unfairly
about some of her um
mothering practices for
child-rearing practices and
you know people
make jokes about some of that stuff but
i actually think um
a good friend of mine knows
her and has been around her son
um and just says what a lovely kitty is
like what a well-adjusted great kitty is
so it's like and we talk about that
today we talk about you know how that's
affected her and how she thinks about
that kind of stuff we of course talk
about clueless and all the classics she
was in arizona crushed babysitter excess
baggage yes
robin uh a little bit about batman robin
yeah i i'm telling you it was like i
didn't have that much time and it was
i i needed many more hours and she has a
new podcast out yes called the uh real
oh real heel the real heel thank you
alicia silverstone um anyway we are uh
so excited to have her i've been
speaking for you too because i know you
are you know i'm excited about lisa
silverstone she's the best we've like
loved her for years and um so i'm i was
excited to talk to i'm excited for you
all to hear let's do this talk so let's
do it um the iconic and kind uh animal
loving
warm
just talented alicia silverstone
life could be a dream
[Music]
well we haven't seen each other in a
while i know it's nice to see your face
it's so nice to see your face yeah you
look great and you're in a beautiful
setting a lot of orchids um
it looks really well curated and you
have a lot of nice photos in the back
i'm peeping in the background is that a
bar probably
yeah there's a bar but i don't use it
it's just nice it's just pretty it's a
it's a show bar
like
you know one person a few years ago sent
me some alcohol and i thought it looks
so beautiful that i sort of it's a
collection but i
never
yeah i mean occasionally but so rarely
do i actually use that thing so if i
sent you like a tennis racket and tennis
balls you would be forced to get a court
well i would be forced to go take
lessons or something
well it looks really nice it's a nice
fake bar and um is this so you do the
podcast just from the home just like
this yes yes why yeah i haven't seen you
in so long also i've never really had
occasion to ask you some of the nerdy
questions i'm hoping to ask um as a fan
of yours
because you know that's uncomfortable to
do in uh
in society at it when we're out at a
club having a dream yeah that was
clueless like yeah so i so i will get to
some of those nerdy ones but i'm i'm
most curious about you sent me it's so
funny this morning i've been doing this
thing it's a sponsor but that's not why
i'm mentioning them they're called
athletic greens and it's um i don't know
if it's a new zealand-based company and
it's just spirulina and a lot of good
like energy producing you you would know
much better than i would what's in this
kind of stuff and and what is helpful
but i'm supposed to drop in d3 i'm
supposed to drop in a little like
and i was frustrated that i left it back
back in la and i opened a package from
you
and it was all your great stuff
including little dropper at d3
nice yes
so thank you but where did so and also i
love your book from uh the kind diet
from a couple years ago is that
did it all come from that was it was it
born of a nutrition uh mindset and then
it kind of branched out is that how you
created this my kind organics i'm going
to hold it up to because no one's
watching i don't know why i'm holding it
up to you you know what it looks like i
do but isn't it pretty it's pretty um uh
there's an elderberry i have and i have
a parkour i love those so my kind
organics came so first you know i wrote
the kind diet maybe 12 or
13 years ago
and then i wrote the kind mama maybe
eight years ago or something
when my son was inside my belly
yeah the midwife my midwife said to me
you know you might want to consider
taking
a prenatal
vitamin
and i thought why would i need a
prenatal i eat so well you know
and i mean excuse me yeah but but then
she kind of convinced me that there are
times you're traveling or times when you
can't get exactly what you're after for
those days or days when you've been
naughty or something why not you know
have an insurance policy so i sort of
she got me on that i thought okay i can
get behind an insurance policy i i just
had a curiosity what is naughty to you
because i know you eat so well you're v
obviously vegan what would constitute as
being naughty to you well naughty for me
is just stuff that doesn't make me feel
good it tastes good but it doesn't feel
good so if i have a bunch of bread or i
have a bunch of and i don't need a
little bit of clean bread i mean like
white bread just forging and butt like
in and out yes or alcohol
and again when i drink i drink really
clean simple things so i'm not really
getting too bad but you know if there's
a real night out yeah or um
or what else uh well when you're
pregnant you're not doing that so i
don't even know what i'm talking about
but you know or just had it sugar or did
you you know if i'm traveling sometimes
sometimes it's impossible to find greens
oh my god
yes i don't want to shame anywhere in
the cup but i was just in utah
and about beautiful lovely people
some great places in salt lake but then
we went i kind of an hour and a half
outside the city it's just outside it's
tough it was tough to find um
so do you bring your own i was i was
just in texas in um
uh round top texas and that's you know
if you're in awe if you're in austin
there's tons of tons of great food but
you step right side outside i think it's
an hour and 15 minute drive and the only
way i could find vegetables at one point
was my bloody mary
oh my god sorry um
anyway
so my journey was that i was really i'm
a really healthy girl and i get pregnant
and i'm like how do i have this
insurance policy so i decide i'm gonna
go find a
prenatal to take
and i'm already in the health community
so i have a good sense of being in the
know about who makes the best vitamins
on the market i bet so i start looking
at those and i find that those vitamins
are low they don't they're they're
wrapped in chemicals like preservative
chemicals preservatives so it would say
like magnesium steroid steroids you
don't want that um
they weren't certified organic they
weren't non-gmo verified meaning they've
been tested to make sure that gmos have
not landed into your crop uh so what's
what's the difference some say non-gm
and people would recognize that i'm
looking at your elder berry right now
and people right now
non-gmo non-gmo does not mean that they
have no gmos in them non-gmo verified
means that they've actually tested to
make sure that there's no gmos that have
landed inside
because sometimes you can be a farmer
who does no gmos but next door you're
next to some awful
conventional farm and they fly over and
unfortunately that's legal that they
just why it flies over so no kidding
that must be so frustrating for the
organic farmer who lives next it is it's
a real battle and at one point people i
mean i think this might still go on but
people who the nasty farmers i like to
think of them as the nasty girls the the
conventional ones who are poisoning us
and our planet they then would sue
organic farmers and say you stole our
our chemicals
the point is i couldn't find a vitamin
on the market that was clean and so i
decided to make them they are certified
organic non-gmo verified they're all
food based that means there is no
fillers no binders no chemicals in there
if you turn the bottle over you'll see
that it'll say things like you know the
actual vegetable say broccoli or basil
leash it's just there's nothing you
can't pronounce how cool
basil and they're layup
basil no so i can't pronounce that one
um the stupid joke i'm sorry but and
there's also a p i love the quote on the
back and it's signed everyone is
personally signed by you that it looks
like every one of them uh it says ps no
gelatin and no refined sugar just real
fruit god they look delicious i gotta
say just they really are
gonna taste them i can't wait thank you
for making thanks for sending me some um
i didn't know your parents were both
british did you have a little accent
when you were a kid well i did and then
i lost it and then i tried to get it
back because i missed it
i bet it's a cool accent
yeah um but my whenever i would my
parents took me to england every summer
and when we were in england um we would
talk about
uh
i i was speaking the english accent the
entire time and then i'd come home and
you know still be speaking in the shack
center then my friends would be like
your lane
would they think would they think you
were being phony or would they think you
were being like the middle
we were so little that i don't know what
they thought or didn't yeah but um it
didn't feel good i think they didn't
like it what was it like in the you were
in the bay area where did you start
acting were you just a kid actor were
you did they start putting you in
commercials and stuff well i don't
really understand time at all so i don't
i don't know if that's your experience
too but i'm just you know i thinking
back to when i was eight years old
beginning this journey
is trippy i mean yeah
do i remember myself yes i do
and it does feel like a lifetime ago it
feels a long time ago and um
[Music]
yeah but you always want i always wonder
how distorted the lens through which i'm
seeing that is you know i'm seeing it
through the lens of somebody who now
knows more and has lived more and um
i i i can only and i have such a poor
memory as it is so i can only recount
little you know moments you know i
remember seeing like empire strikes back
in the theater that was like a formative
i think i was scared of darth vader and
there are certain glimpses of
my upbringing but it's really really few
and far between i don't know if you feel
that way no i have a lot of memories oh
you do yes i do i remember i remember
breastfeeding on my mom isn't that weird
and i love my mommy and i remember
somebody changing me when i was very
little and i
i remember my brother tormenting i mean
i remember that i remember too all the
good and all the bad yeah wow
yeah and then there's stuff i can't
remember at all but
this is the first big nerdy thing i'm
gonna say is i'm very excited about the
wonder years episode that you did i i
didn't realize that was your first uh
screen role that was my first acting i
mean i did i got two commercials before
that and uh wow
the wonder years was a you know what it
was the wonder years had me go back
about five times but it was down to me
and this girl lisa gerber and we were we
became friends in the casting process
because
we were kept they kept going back and
back they could not decide between her
and i it was for this bigger part she
got the part so it was for this bigger
part and um and i was devastated i was
quite crushed when i didn't get the part
but yeah
anyway lisa gerber got the bigger this
whatever this part was it was a bigger
part but then they said it was like it
was like a consolation prize i got the
other one oh man wait what lisa gerber
sounds familiar do you remember what was
it uh
was it
it's not it wasn't a lead part it was
like a guest star yeah yeah yeah but it
was for the girl do you remember she he
goes somewhere like the summer
at the lake the lake lisa grover yes yes
oh my god why do you know her name and
why do you remember well that is a good
thing do you have a crush on her oh i'm
sure
some of those memories yes maybe i did
maybe i did so what happened how come
you remember lisa gregory well it's so
exciting you know what's so fun well i i
recently went back and watched um a lot
of those early episodes because fred was
on the show and um
and and i'd love i love the show to the
point where i my brother and i joke
about this a lot of my
early memories i conflate without this
is so embarrassing i conflate a lot of
my own memories with episodes of the
show
and like i had a so you're not sure if
it's you or them yes or i think like oh
my god i remember going to a
drive-through with this girl
and i remember hearing brown eyed girl
play and then i'll think oh wait a
minute no that wasn't me
but i have like i have the kind of like
much more innocent much lamer memories
that kevin arnold had and the lisa
gerber episode oh because it's a classic
too it's great tv i mean it's funny not
to rub it in that you didn't get it it's
okay
i'm all right oh you've moved on
wow oh that's a little thing oh but you
would have been
great in that part i mean
you know what i don't know if you know
what happened with fred uh savage and me
and paul savant sabiano josh josh josh
josh josh
so
while you're on set you know so i only
have that one scene yeah just to i just
say to him you know if you're going to
pick you're going to have to pick me up
in your car yeah you're going to go on
this date whatever yes and i'm on set
and at the end of the day
fred savage says to me you know can i
have your phone number
and of course
and so i give him my phone number but
how old is he
i don't know but i live in san francisco
and i live with my family
i don't even know how i got there i
don't know what i'm doing here but
somehow i was there
and
and i
my parents weren't there and so i go
home and our house phone cause we'd have
cell phones
our house phone was a fat my dad's fax
machine too for work um
when when he tried to call me he got a
fax machine and did not believe it was
me or whatever so oh
which to a lot to to younger people
listening uh no it sounded it was like a
high-pitched like scream right like yeah
exactly
yeah
yeah it was a really off-putting sound
and then i don't know why josh saviano
reached me now maybe he was just more
persistent but he
though he and i ended up being friends
and like you know
he was i think as a he was trying to
date me as a yeah we are young people so
i don't even know what that means versus
babies you know yeah you must have been
14. but it was sweet he took me on a few
dates and we were just friends and it
was oh my god was was he um
so how did he have your number yeah
i don't know that's what i'm wondering i
don't know how that happened but lisa
gerber and so lisa me and josh would
sort of drive around together in josh's
car because josh had a car and i was 14
or 15. oh my god yeah
that's wild that's wild i did like it
now i'm just imagining it's funny i'd
said this to fred too and he he must get
it all the time but i really feel like i
know
say with yourself i mean i've been
watching you so long but those that i
would watch them go on adventure so i
just feel like i know those people um
it was it was so surreal to talk to him
but
and to now imagine you and lisa gerber
and
paul pfeiffer driving around what um
you people must have that response to
you do you find that that people that
are very familiar with you especially
people my age
yeah i think people are but it's it sort
of creates a sort of warmth if they're
in your industry they know they don't
know you because they hopefully they
know that you're playing a character and
that you're not those are not your
circumstances but yeah it's one of those
things that's it's really difficult to
understand sometimes i think
but in general people are just very warm
they'll come over to me yeah just can i
hug you and like of course and what
doesn't want to hug
and then well i guess it depends well i
suppose it depends but most mostly it's
quite lovely and
and then
you know you just sort of move on
but
the attention must come in different
forms like i would imagine
now it's all good but but like i'm sure
there was a time where
like male attention especially because
you in these iconic videos and
you were you were
adored by
men kids uh including josh saviano was
that uncomfortable did that ever become
like uh
this is getting weird
it's funny you know even you know zach
graff he's a good friend he's a good
friend of mine and i just worked with
him recently and it was so fun and he's
just lovely but whenever he and i hang
out he cannot forget the fact that i was
an important part of his childhood yeah
i get it in a gross way and so every
time i see him he feels the need to go
into detail what about
a kind of and i'm like okay
i get it you had a crush on me are we
ever gonna get past this but it's kind
of funny so he's like he's probably the
worst version of it in a funny great way
yeah
but
but other than that no it's it's it's i
remember no i'm just teasing i really
like sakraf and thinking no i know but
when i but when i was a kid i remember
the hard i remember being in one of
those round table press junket thingies
that you do for movies
and i was sitting at a table with you
know tons of different people from
different countries who are doing the
interviews so just for context for
people they have different they kind of
you're sitting with at least i don't
know 10 15 uh other people uh when
you're younger journalists they were and
they'll just kind of push recording
devices in in front of them to get you
and
everyone so they'll just take turns
asking questions um
and it's an effective way to do it the
efficient way to do it because they're
sending you from room to room to room to
room to room so you're all kind of
moving around
so you're doing this all day long and
your heads are going to explode
i don't know about you but i don't love
her i'm not a press check it not crazy
about it yeah i have fun doing it you
know what i like to do and i'm sorry to
interrupt i like to
uh try to give myself a a sentence that
i have to say or some subject like i
have to say the phrase like if we were
to do it together i would say okay this
next one you have to somehow work in
well who doesn't love
it's fun like well who doesn't love
cinnamon
you know so
you have to get you have to say that
sentence and that makes it like fun yeah
yeah all right
but i was in a press junket and the guy
said to me um
how big what is your bra size
and i was like 16 and i just oh my
god
i just watched i just was so creeped out
now now i would just laugh i would be
like what are you
yeah what's your underwear size yeah but
i was 16 and i was not even a person you
know you're just trying to find yourself
so i that's when it felt very exposed
now in that particular case does
somebody say to him does another adult
in the room say to him like dude
i think i think my manager stood up and
said we're that we're done now thank you
oh god i think sounds wild
uh yeah that must be especially for a 16
year old kid um so occasionally it could
be weird but um and then you don't meet
zach craft till much later so you know
zach braff just got weird recently
no zach and i know each other i actually
auditioned i uh zach came in an audition
for a movie that i was doing that i was
producing a hundred years ago and he
hadn't become zach brath yet and i
remember i left that meeting
with a picture of him and i filed it
away in my little cabinet of like this
guy i have to work with this guy this
guy
this guy is amazing and then was that
excess baggage no
we didn't we didn't end up doing this
movie because various reasons um and so
i just kept running into him i saw him
in a play i saw him in a
i saw him in a play in new york and i
didn't see him i didn't remember him so
i'm talking to david harbor and i'm
talking to these people who are in this
play and then zac graf comes over to me
and he says do you remember me and i
said i do and he said but i was just in
this place and no i didn't remember i
didn't see you in the play
well you can spin that into a compliment
with an actor you could be like god you
were such a you just lost yourself in
the role he was i didn't even notice him
and then that's funny that's funny and
then um but we can well you must know
donald very well
i do know donald but i know zach better
than donald in fact because even donald
and i work together but zach and i keep
running into each other all the time and
have since been friends and since worked
with each other but i love me some
donald he's loving it yes uh friend of
the show good friend yeah i've just i've
been lucky enough to work with him
several times and he and you know i so
i've been around him a lot and so i know
i know how many people come up to him
about uh the clueless i mean it's they
or yell things at him and and i'm
keeping it right because i'm keeping it
i mean i would do it don't keep it real
cause i'm keeper i would say to him all
the time and um
he he really embraced it uh and i think
i remember asking him about you and he
said the same of you that it was it was
you know it's one of those things that
because it's an iconic movie uh what do
you what are you gonna do you have to
kind of probably i don't know what
that's like to be an iconic movie but
you have to embrace the love for it
is is that the case i just think we do
there's a there's there's a shared
experience that we all have and
and it's never been anything but joyous
you know why why
the this thing that brings people so
much joy i know and old people and
little people and new
new little people are discovering it
and they just love it so i i can't how
could that be a bad thing it's there's
many bad things in life i don't think
that is not one of them why dwell on
something i know that's true i
i i it's it's it's something that's very
special to me i know a lot of people
listening um
so it's nice to hear and it was always
nice to see the way people would
approach donald about it it was only
from a place of like real like
i've never ever met someone who's like
dude i hate clueless
no
people
like it i'm always surprised when boys
like it boy some boys are even it sounds
like you it's like loved it loved it and
and
and i didn't realize that you know well
because it it's it was also um an
introduction to a a world that i had
never
experienced before i never seen i was
from the east coast and so it was such
it felt like that and and the and the
lost boys felt like well that's what
it's like to be in la to be and i was
fascinated by california and um
and the way people talk and dress and
how it's it's it's funny now because
obviously it's so nostalgic but at the
time i remember thinking this is just
cool
this is like how cool people are and and
i didn't understand the satire i didn't
understand um i just thought you were
cool and
i i and the whole thing just looked like
so much fun to make it looked like a
summer camp
what was that the experience i think
that was the experience for everyone but
me
what was what was because because donald
and paul and brecken they came and went
you know they had a few days here a few
days there was like i'm just coming in
and i think they were all living
together which i didn't know at the time
i learned that recently
that paul brecken and donald were
hanging out living in an apartment
together during that time so they were
having a ball
but you had all the work to do i was
working day in and day out and i just
come off of i you know i had done eight
or nine movies before clueless oh my god
so i had been back to back to back i was
exhausted the day we started i mean
really exhausted to tears
and um i was starting to get an ulcer i
didn't know about healthy eating yet so
the combination of tiredness stress and
eating a bunch of dairy was not helping
me and so
and so here i was you know just trying
to survive really and
and i loved playing cher and i love the
character but the interaction of the
camaraderie was not my thing oh yeah i
wasn't there to make friends i was at
her work and go home and sleep and work
and go home and sleep work and go sleep
and i had so much to do a little like
share i mean
a little like overwhelmed by life like
cher uh
what was that way of speaking was that
language at all that vernacular was that
familiar to completely foreign
completely yeah yeah wow wow no i didn't
talk like that i didn't have any
interest in clothes i'm not like
oh yeah no you're not the closest part
of cher is when she figures out that she
wants to save pismo beach you know the
people
that's the part of her to be everything
else is not like me at all
[Music]
man i really like thrive market it's
been helping you thrive it sure has it's
an online marketplace that focuses and
they have a mission to make healthy
living easy and affordable for everyone
and it's a monthly or any annual monthly
or annual membership uh whatever is best
i think you save a little bit of money
if you do the annual year and i think i
think you'll find that when you do the
monthly you're going to wish you just
signed up for the annual because they
have everything from healthy pantry
essentials to sustainable meat and
seafood to non-toxic cleaning and beauty
products all and they deliver it all to
your door if you find a price lower
elsewhere they will even match it that's
right a low sugar keto gluten free zero
waste buy poc own brands you can filter
by over 90 values and lifestyles to find
exactly what works best for you it just
makes shopping easy if you're the type
of person who doesn't like to spend the
time to go and scour the aisles and you
can just uh input all your information
all your desires right into the computer
and they do it for you and sorry and
they have such great products i've been
really enjoying this um
vegan chili
they have great coffees and tea i
ordered a um an extra virgin olive oil
from them and it came right to the door
now we have uh a special deal for our
listeners 40 off your first order when
you join thrive market today and a free
gift worth over 50 dollars so
can your grocery store do that mine
can't
well now it can yes right when you go to
thrivemarket.com
long you join today to get 40 off your
first order and a free gift worth over
50
that's
i v t-h-r-i-v-e market
dot com slash long to get forty percent
off your first order and a free gift
worth over fifty dollars that's thrive
market dot com slash long
hello hello
[Music]
was it the aerosmith videos that kind of
set into motion all of those was it just
an overnight as overnight as i imagined
where it went videos i think the first
thing i did was the crush that was my
first i mean of course it was wonder
years but prior after post-wonder years
there was the crush
and which lisa gerber was also up for
and the crush i got awarded things at
the mtv movie awards for best villain
which i took very seriously
and um
best villain i mean what an incredible
award
yeah and also for um best newcomer i
think and so then and then i did some
aerosmith videos but i then also did le
nouvemonde a french film with alan
corneau and james gondolfini oh my god
and um
we did that in french
and french in
yes the island of france oh my god we
did that in france and um just outside
of paris actually and um
parish
and what else did i do i did i did a
movie that joel
schumacher
produced called the babysitter that oh
sure um
and then i did
hideaway with jeff goldblum so yeah so
between between the between the crush
and clueless was a lot of movies i did a
movie i did a movie with raquel welch i
did a movie with time daily oh my god
what was it
what did i do just divas what and
no i know
wow was that how batman and was joel
schumacher's involvement in that how
your your role on batman i think
clueless was what made that robin happen
and um but i had previously worked with
them and guy furland was the director
and i'm trying to think there was a
bunch more i mean i was working my pants
off before i got to
uh true crime i did this movie called
true crime
and um anyway so i did all these movies
and then clueless and so clueless was
the big you know
the biggest one and did you know going
into that i mean was that
absolutely i mean heckerling was you had
no idea it was going to be what it was
but was there was there a little bit
more i mean i don't how could there be
you're talking about like time daily and
richard welsh and these big they almost
felt big all i knew was well i was never
trying to i did i didn't i wasn't a girl
who followed movies when i was a kid so
i had no i had no interest i didn't know
oh i want to be a movie
i didn't want to be
anything i just loved acting and i um
and mostly i had
my reverence was for theater because i
grew up going to the theater with my dad
and so to me a real actor did theater
not film and so here i was so here i was
watching you know i didn't
i wasn't watching a bunch of movies
hoping i'd get in one i just was showing
up to audition and have fun and love
that
and so i think that made a healthier
state of mind because i didn't have an
agenda totally yes and the fame probably
didn't exist live on you the way it was
it didn't
it didn't until it happened and that was
the rude awakening because i didn't i
didn't know i wasn't looking for it i
didn't want it i didn't know what it was
and so there it then it was there and it
was really hard to deal with but but i
it's different now i think kids are sort
of some people are striving to have that
instead of striving to be good at their
craft and i think that's really tricky
yes yes yes
so anyway i i just know that when
clueless happened i was really excited
to play this role because i thought she
was so different than me
and because she was so um
she was so
uh
i didn't know that i was funny and so i
just played it as serious as i could
and um and and i just knew that amy
heckerling had done fast times at
richmond high that was really wonderful
i knew that yeah but i had i really
didn't know what would be of it and so
it was all a really pleasant surprise
that it did really well and people
really liked it
did you ever question the language that
i would imagine just reading that script
i i would imagine there'd be a real
challenge in overcoming some of that as
if and some of the some of that language
or or was it just as simple as i trust
amy heckerling um this this makes in
context of what's happening in the
script it makes sense
yeah i mean i think that i had i
remember practicing a lot
how to sort of get the words out in a
way that was um
because he always had a mouthful to say
you know yes oh my god yeah and the
speeches she would make debating in her
debate class all the time you know there
was just a lot of words to it so
um
but i it was different it wasn't how i
talked for sure yeah but i didn't but i
wasn't concerned about it i was just
i knew amy was
amy was just so cool i would ask her
questions i'd ask her nerdy actor
questions and she'd go oh doll don't
worry you know she was just
like you've got
it yeah
that's funny i i didn't know that you
were a little like a thespian and um
striving to do theater is that was that
part of the impetus for doing then
later the graduate
well the first play i did was a play
called um
oh god i forgot what it was
something dog uh
i can't remember the name of the first
play but i played a lesbian coach coke a
lesbian who's on coke who overdoses on
stage
and wow that was my first play the next
day i don't know what it was called this
next play i did was the graduate and
then i started i've done eight plays and
um
and four on broadway and i love theater
so much if you could put and i think
that's where i saw you i've been coming
to the theater and yes you and i
yeah
yes and i've seen you on stage you're
great on stage it's always a surprise to
see somebody who is i don't know why it
should be you know to see somebody who's
known for doing film to be that good on
on stage um
it really shouldn't be but i guess we're
it's hard to separate sometimes um
so what what was so when you are then
having all the success as a film actor
is there
are your parents concerned is there a
sense that like this is a runaway train
that we have to somehow manage because
you were so young how how do you balance
all of that all the attention and the
people knowing who you are how does a
young person balance that
i mean i could ask you the same question
well yeah
but not really because i at least i was
older i was like you know i i think even
being into your 20s having
a little bit more yeah so i wasn't like
god if that happened to me in high
school
i
i'm afraid to imagine what i would do
with it i think i would i think i would
probably covet it more i think i would
maybe use it in a
uh to my advantage you know i think i
would probably use it more um
i don't know i don't think it'd be
healthy for my
for me you seem a lot more grounded yes
well i just wanted to push it all away
and that's how i landed in what i do you
know that i'm an activist and that i
make write these books and i have my
podcast that's coming out all about
healing
right that was my way of healing in a
way was to just push away i was you know
i pushed away a lot of great
opportunities i will say that too in
this business
but it was my survival because i didn't
have the skills i didn't there is no i
didn't take a course in how what do you
do when you become super famous
right isn't that interesting yeah and
you could teach one now
what do you do
yeah and if you don't have the correct
support system around you it's really
tricky so you're just trying to survive
and
i think my way of handling it was to go
to africa and to um you know try to help
the i was trying to help the elephants
that were dying of this disease i made a
documentary there and then i went to i
went to peru to try and save the
rainforest and you know do these things
that were
so um
life-changing and exciting and really i
was so passionate about and i felt like
having my luckily to this day so i i
have a son that i'm so in love with and
i have a job that i'm really in love
with i love acting i just i have two
films coming out right now oh [ __ ]
and i have tons of stuff that just came
out in terms of stuff that's coming out
and i'm working like crazy but what i'm
always also doing is completely and
utterly filled up with my activism and
my interest in helping people be healthy
and live the best lives they can
was it having your son that was you
think the catalyst for a lot of that or
was it simply um
or was it being exposed to something a
lot more
at all a higher purpose it happened a
lot earlier than my son it was very when
i was it was really right after clueless
i just rejected a lot of it and turned
turned away from a lot of it and in
doing that i just was able to put my
heart and soul into this activism
learning about the world learning about
the problems the real life problems that
are happening right now for people nine
million people don't eat a year and they
die of hunger
nine million people die of hunger a year
i can't believe the things they focus on
when that's how people don't know well
yeah i know i know when that when that
that puts everything in perspective and
you must think like two just personally
when you're getting this kind of
attention and there's a focus and and
you see these truths these really like
hard to to swallow truths it must it
must make it seem that much more absurd
that like
i i this movie i did or this thing that
i had fun doing is getting all this
attention and time spent talked about
and yet there is this number nine
million human beings that must really
strike you i also through age have
learned to love the fact that we can
enjoy things like while there's nine
million people dying of hunger what i
mean is the attention that the the
division of our country the division of
people's ideas the loss of of freedom of
speech the loss yeah yeah the the the um
the misinformation coming out from our
government you know
all of these things that are happening
this corrupt system that we live in you
know i just can't believe that
you know nine million people die a year
of hunger 12 million die a year of
cancer 12 million of diabetes you know
diabetes and obesity like the amount of
people dying from diseases a year the
amount of people flooding the hospitals
per year from
just
the foods they eat i know i know
so much of the covid is the result of i
mean so many of those hospitalizations
were due to
a much more pervasive underlying problem
of obesity
no so i'm so i'm so absolutely uh
moved by the real stuff at the same time
no i never say how can you like clueless
when there's people dying because i
understand that we all find joy
in entertainment and sure like great
books and great music and art really
truly what happened is i got to get back
to the artist that i am and so
the film that just came out
actually on friday came out um
last survivor is an art project i went
to do and the other one the requiem was
this incredible vietnamese filmmaker
levon kit and i went and did this you
know i just threw myself into it i
basically just threw myself off a cliff
except it was into an ocean and um
that's good
and it's these are films that i'm really
proud of and i get to be an artist so
great i'm happy to be able to do it all
and i'm having so much fun on my podcast
because i'm oh good yes it's the real
heel the real heel and it's people can
it's on and remember when i called you
to ask you for help
yeah it's so sweet
yes and i was so like god it was such a
it was such a task it was um it was so
daunting because i'm so rarely asked to
help anybody
you and i both could never get on the
phone to actually have the conversation
but i i know but i was just
energetically you helped oh i i was i
was just so um
i felt so honored that you wanted me
wanted my help which you no longer need
because it's out it's on i heart um it
is so good it's so what what is
fulfilling about it what is the thing
that fulfills you in doing it is it
satisfying your curiosity is it what
we're talking about you know so my i
we're talking about my activism that was
born in in my work it with animals and
and africa and peru for the rainforest
and
this this developing understanding that
we can make change in the world and that
we can feel if we want to
and um
so then i wrote these books and then i
have my vitamins and i've always just
been
a little baby activist and so the
podcast allows me to speak to other
people who are doing this and really get
to the heart of
how are we going to heal our communities
and our
selves
and our planet how are we going to do
this and so i today i was just talking
today to a mass amazing gastro um you
know gi doctor who is just
so deeply wonderful and i got so excited
and then i'm talking to peter singer
who's this man who is at the forefront
of animal activism in the beginning of
time and then i'm talking to um um kevin
smith who changed his life so much and
i'm just having these relationships
you're allowing kevin smith to talk i'm
allowing kevin's vision yeah he's going
to love him i already did it oh you did
it he's great yeah
he's an old friend
alicia you are so in love with animals
you're such a great um
advocate on their behalf what was the do
you remember those we're talking about
early childhood stuff do you remember
the seeds of that do you remember when
that
took root
i do i
i remember with my mom we would be
driving down the street and i would see
a dog in the road and my mom would pull
over and we would run after the dog now
mind you that's not how you get a dog
who's running away to come towards you
but um i learned that the hard way
but one time my mom pulled over on a
freeway and we pulled over onto the edge
of the freeway and his her little girl
went running down the freeway and i was
trying to catch this dog
and um i can't say whether that was good
or not i i did the same thing alicia but
it was only for turtles i was i was at i
still do it i mean i'll run across a
six-lane
you know just to and they're usually
when they're that far into the highway
they're usually
uh no longer i'm so glad that you did
that oh you're constantly still stuck
doing it uh it might this might be
played one day uh this is gonna sound
arrogant but if i if i get if that's the
way i die
this little soundbite might be played
one day like oh he's he was prone to
doing them
yeah and i remember a kid in school when
i was little isaac franco he stepped on
beetles in front of me and i got so
upset with him and said why would you
crush these beetles and we would just
get into these physical i mean man we
are probably
young
crushy flirty vibe
but but we are fighting and physically
fighting over these beetles and i just
couldn't understand they're not hurting
you just walk around them oh my god i'm
embarrassed to say this i was watching
the bachelor last night only because my
brother was and i walked into the room
whatever and and there was there was a
girl who was a woman who was on a date
with the bachelor and she
told a story it was actually quite sad
her cousin had passed away but she was
recounting a memory of her and her
cousin and she said
i remember every time i see a firefly i
think of my cousin because when we were
little
i would catch these fireflies and i
would this is the kind of person i i am
i would just
smear them on my face
and uh to glow
proud of it thought it was an adorable
memory and the bachelor this like dumb
hunky guy was like i love that that's so
great without ever saying god if a girl
said that to me on a date i'd be like
hold on disgusting
that's also wrong with him
i know he was a lot more are we going to
get in trouble and cancel pretty good i
don't know
uh maybe maybe maybe you can't say
psychopath maybe we'll get into trouble
by psychopaths will be offended they'll
be fine um
yeah but it was it was wild i was like
that's an aw that's a wild thing to do
that's not a cute that's not cool story
just sorry that's not cool i know i know
we should let's cancel her before she
cancels us um well you've already
cancelled isaac franco he's got he's
gone no he's freaking he'll never work
again he's forgiven okay um
well
that's i we sound like we were very
similar kids and were you allowed to
have although yours took root in a much
uh deeper more meaningful way i have a i
this is another reason i'm inspired by
you i i
want to eat less meat i want to eat no
meat eventually
that's amazing
i'm working toward it um what what is
what is a good
uh
bridge food that you would recommend i i
love impossible meat i love beyond me we
talk about that on the show well first
of all
i'm so proud of you and so excited that
you're trying and that is so beautiful
just saying out loud that you want to do
that
is so huge justin and
i'm grateful forever to know that and
and so you just keep trying and in la we
have you been to nixon beverly
no okay write that down immediately i am
and and get the avocado sticky rice it's
insane right and their salads are all
really good but if you and
and then their breakfast they have a
breakfast like
you know egg mcmuffin kind of thing
that's really good but have you i know
you've been to crossroads duh
yes have you have you been to sugar taco
no you must go to sugar taco and get the
carne asadas tacos they're so good
now are they made with um god what's
that great i'm blanking on the name of
it
it's all it's all more natural and and
healthy than having like you know the
fakie meats yes i thought seitan was a
fakie meat i thought it was compressed
wheat no well it's it is a it's
processed like tofu's products
okay but it's not like impossible burger
where while that's delicious
you that's party food that's not daily
consumption food do you know okay okay
yes i do i mean it's daily consumption
food if you're replacing meat but when
you are what you have access and you
have information i can help you to eat
you want to eat you want to eat beans
instead of meat yeah
jackfruit i love sure like kind of
hearty you need protein jackfruit's
delicious but you need protein and you
get your protein and your beans and
you're getting i mean there's protein in
everything by the way but yeah but
except for fruit there's no protein in
fruit but you get protein and everything
but to get a concentrated amount of
protein which you need we all need you
want to have beans seitan tofu tempeh
and what's delicious about the carne
asada at sugar taco is it literally is
um it's just seitan so it's it's it is
concentrated from the wheat gluten so if
you're celiac you can't have it but if
you're not celiac get all over that
stuff because it's so delicious there's
a brand of seitan that you can get at
the grocery store that has a chorizo
flavor
and we and we make that when we put that
in our tacos with our refried beans
that's cool and it's good and if you've
not been to romage have you been to
bromage no okay so first of all you
should go on my website thekinelife.com
and okay and you should look up los
angeles restaurants and i have a whole
list of restaurants and what's and i'm
very bossy and tell you what to order
there good
i need that but for homage is this
french dude who was sick and tired of
the bad vegan cheese and he made the
most you it's on sunset and laurel go
there now it's so good and get his
sandwich he makes this incredible
sandwich
wow but he has ricotta he has every kind
of cheese you want and then of course
there's bio life that's really delicious
and um at the grocery store and and
and foragers is really good forager's
cheese and all their stuff is really
good
so amazing okay
i'm going to check out the kind life.com
yes and you can anytime you're wondering
anything you can pretty much type it
into the kindlife.com and up it will
come like how do i want to do my laundry
in a healthy more conscious way oh then
there's amazing does your son does he
ever say oh they had like this in school
or they
the kids are talking about meat does he
is he show any curiosity about eating
meat he did when he was about five or
six there was a moment where he said you
know mommy
who's making that noise
um
what is somebody's tummy is very strange
i hear you um oh is that that you're one
of your dogs it's one of the dogs
it sounds like somebody's
it's just a funny noise anyway somebody
farting is one of the dogs farting it's
not farting it sounds
like somebody's crying
quietly while they're sleeping uh i just
i love when dogs dream and they have the
like inside bark
yeah um
i also
i also just read an article about an
influencer have you read this who is
bottling and selling
her own
farts
i wish i were making that up
but alicia's contorting her face into as
she should into a scratched um
quizzical
slightly something's happening she's now
looking behind her dickson where are you
what's wrong
dickson
he must be
i don't know whatever oh okay well wrong
okay
sorry dixon how many dogs do you have
three oh
yeah cute are they all bit
like pit bulls they're all rescued my
big pit and then the two little ones
were my mom's when she passed away i
took oh oh i'm sorry to hear that thank
you i'm sorry to hear that
that was was that recent it's like two
years ago oh [ __ ] i'm sorry yeah have
you lost a parent yet uh my i mean this
is gonna sound my grandma died a year
ago it was just the year anniversary
she was 104 but but so vibrant um
and so i
i know i'm anticipating having a very
difficult time
uh no i haven't yet lost a parent
but it must be rough as hell yeah must
be the worst
it's real yeah it's really real
yeah oh man yeah sorry
thank you
um sorry was she a veggie was she yeah
yeah
was she a vegan was she um it sounds
like an animal lover but was she a vegan
my mom was an animal lover and i got a
lot of my love for animals from my mom
for sure she was she was so ahead of her
time because she lived through world war
two so she always used to think and
she's and she's english as you would
always say remember the rule
and what that meant was don't waste
anything so she didn't they don't they
don't mean to be environmentalists but
they just are you know like she said she
would and she was
my mom is so cute and what we bonded
over was so sweet she would i would give
her all my products that i didn't want
that people sent me stuff that was still
natural but you know i try them all i
sort of test stuff out for people and
then put them on my blog telling you the
best ones and yeah so the things i
didn't want i would give to my mommy and
she'd be so happy to have them and so
she'd collect when she was done she
would scrape out every last cut the
thing open cut the i mean there's not a
drop left and she would save the bags
and send them to show them to me
of look look look how i used every
little oh my god and when she does the
dishes she would hold all the water in a
bucket and then put the water into the
plants in the yard she's just really
mindful
and doesn't waste a thing but it's not
coming from her understanding of the
earth it's coming from not wanting to
waste waste yes oh my god how austere
and
yeah what a time to live would she
describe that time i mean bot i mean to
be bombed to be bombarded uh
they were in bunkers and stuff i imagine
they were under
yeah he was out in the country at that
time because
but yeah it was really it's a different
time it's a different thing and we in
our generation all of us we don't know
what that is oh my god i know the
problems we face i know i know um
well is it was that that must be
that was
something's happening she's so alicia's
looking around so it's a sound it sounds
like in the gym
oh yes okay
so she's gonna get to the bottom of it
no and it's not you tiny where is dixon
ty tiny and pinto
are and now here comes pinto
hold on a second
i'm dying to see tiny because i imagine
she's getting up to
find dixon
and they're all big dogs
she's open she's letting dixon in
it looks like a beautiful sunny day in
l.a
i'm looking at a cloudy dreary sky here
in connecticut
so what
there's a bone outside that he wanted to
get to and it's so rude that he's doing
that it's like crying over his bone now
i understand well he can also be saying
we're going overtime we are which we are
and i'm so sorry
uh so it's actually good that he did
that and if that was very sweet that's
very sweet sweet of him um okay
we just have a lightning round if you'll
enjoy that's right okay
um
one quick thing you said about there i
just want you know that wild bear
had a moment where he wanted to try
things
he didn't try it but he was tempted he i
gave him permission i said you can try
bear your son yeah you asked me what it
was yes yes and he said bear he said um
he said mommy can i try that i said
absolutely you can try it ask your
friend to let you try it
and then because i gave him permission
he didn't want to
oh so so he just wouldn't do it and i
and i remember he was there we were at a
pizza place and we were getting a vegan
pizza for his birthday he was so excited
and he was looking reaching and there
was a piece of pepperoni that had come
under the glass and he was like mommy
look mommy look
and i said go ahead try it take it
and he was like no
so he didn't he
now he's 10 years old and he's so proud
of how he is and he loves animals and he
cares about the earth and he recognizes
how it feels in his body
and and we just walked the watch the
octopus teacher and he was crying oh my
god yes
i think that he's just a really
compassionate conscious intelligent
little boy
so far is making these choices for
himself his dad is not vegan his dad is
offered him meat all the time and bear
just doesn't want it so there may come a
time where he changes and we'll deal
with that when the time comes but so far
he's super committed where did the name
bear i'm fascinated by naming children
how do you settle on a name for a child
how did you land on bear it's a great
name it's a cool name thank you um i
didn't know if i was having a girl or a
boy i presumed i was having a girl and i
had three names for a girl that i was
completely happy with and in love with
oh really no kidding boys did that i
didn't know what were you gonna say
well it'd be harder to find three that i
loved i did i have three that i loved
and then my
husband of the time
christopher he really had all these guy
names that were axel
um
after charles bukowski he had
like the short version of his name i
can't remember what it is he had a chuck
chuck i think if i don't even think it's
chuck jazz it's something funny i don't
know what it is anyway he had all these
names that iggy you know iggy okay yeah
like rock and roll yeah and i
was not excited about any of them to be
honest and his mom who's this very
republican conservative woman suggested
bear and suggested independently blue
and i'd what and i had all i had always
wanted to name my child blue
blue because i had a friend who had a
kid named blue and i thought it was so
beautiful um so anyway but by the time i
went through my birth i didn't give a
[ __ ] at that point i was like whatever
yeah and so
and so i think when he was born iggy it
is yeah whatever and so he was ziggy
startups yeah he's fine moon boot let's
name him
we used to we used to call him barracuda
and moon boot when he was in my belly as
a joke but then um
now he was born and i just thought we
just looked at him and sort of went this
one this what does he look like and we
determine bear blue
a little bear bear blue how cool
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
hello hello again you're booming over
[Music]
okay lightning round thank you also for
indulging thank you for having me so fun
oh man it's just such a blast to talk to
you um what is your favorite emoji
i have a lot sorry okay your go-to most
common i really like the little when
they're hungry and oh a little
she's sticking her tongue out oh like uh
like it's like naughty
because i was using the one with the two
um tears here and i thought that meant
yes um
crying i thought it meant
crying i can't remember what i thought
because i've stopped using it because
the person told me no it means that
you're stressed and worried
oh i was using one wrong i don't know
which one it was oh
like you're not the last not the cry
laughter no not that one a different one
anyway that's funny okay so you wouldn't
want to say oh that's funny um i didn't
know that that's good to know but i like
a lot of emojis i know it's not cool to
like emojis some some people i text they
go please don't use emojis stop it
they think you find them really useful i
just love them they're so fun
yeah and it also helps like set a tone
for something that might be yes
misinterpreted yeah i think yeah um
uh who would be talking about people
having crushes on you uh who was your
first celebrity crush your first michael
j fox
mine too yeah
well yeah i mean i i think it was
probably
carrie fisher in return of the jedi but
um
i i loved michael j fox that's so funny
i love him
oh my god i think i i sat down to write
him a fan letter and then decided that
was not a good idea but i did attempt
that's so funny i still i have one of my
teeth that fell out when i was like
seven i must have been seven and and it
said my birthday i don't know i have
this weird thing right like kept it and
i said michael i was eight or seven and
michael j fox turned 25 three weeks
later like some
weirdo uh stalker who would associate
losing a tooth with i don't know how i
did that
um he that was a huge day for me when he
started not to brag but he started
following me
on instagram he does he i hope he still
does i don't look and he's he unfollowed
me but oh it was he it was huge and i
geeked out on him he was so good in the
good wife
oh so
i mean
i think he doesn't get enough credit for
what a great actor he is um and
yeah i just loved family ties growing um
okay what is your what is your favorite
ice cream flavor that's so funny
i mean
back in the day it was bubble gum
you know
with bubble gums in it but i love i also
i also loved mint chip
and rocky road
but now i don't really i don't love ice
cream that much anymore i mean even like
really good bam bam van lewin vegan ice
cream can be great if you get you know
they have amazing stuff
yes but i i've noticed that all all in
all i think i
i don't get i was drooling over it but i
do i don't
you do i was just gonna launch into my
michael j fox impression do you do
impressions of anybody do you have any
good impressions
no but what i do do is if i'm talking
about someone i can take on their sort
of characteristics characteristics in
explaining something
so i do that but i don't do
impersonations but more like that makes
sense oh my friend would be talking
about his sister and i might start
looking like her you know sort of yeah
yes that's interesting i find when i'm
done watching a movie if i watch a movie
with accents um
you know especially like australian i
i'll start slipping into
kristen bell calls it um accent
tourette's which is also probably
offensive but australian is so hard
how do you just i'm sure i don't do it
well okay fine i want to do it well um
but you're uh what is your favorite
holiday
i love thanksgiving i've always loved
thanksgiving because i love making a big
vegan feast and showing people how
delicious it can be and that you don't
miss a thing
okay so what's the centerpiece what's is
it tofurky no god i mean sorry tofurkey
but no
there's just so many now we're offending
so many sewing funnies so many different
people um there's so many different
things you can do sometimes i do the cut
the turkey cutlets from um gardein those
are incredible the bread and turkey
cutlets sometimes i do um
uh
what's it called uh field roast sausages
sometimes i make in the kind diet i have
a book for this yummy tofu that's
stuffed with gravy and stuffing
sometimes i make a big pumpkin and stuff
it with things you know make it how cool
but also it doesn't have to be a
centerpiece because what ends up
happening is there's so much freaking
food when you do all the different
things like and and i'm such a foodie
that we're not just making
lame green beans they're delicious green
beans yes yes those are the center
pieces yes so everything becomes i mean
i've never had a thanksgiving where
people didn't roll out of here stuffed
out of their minds but not feeling like
they wanted to die you know yes that's
not
that's nice
um being mean and like you know
i don't i find it so funny that we're
saying thanks for what we have while
being so destructive
murderous destructive choices like it
doesn't make any sense
i mean we should be fasting if anything
if we're really grateful you're right
you know have reverence for the life and
but instead of sparing more give me my
things more i know i thank god i know
just shut up gluttonous monsters
i know man you make such a good case for
um austerity and for veganism um
what is what is an acclaim what is a
movie that you were that you haven't
seen like an acclaimed movie that you're
embarrassed to admit you haven't seen
where people like maybe shame you for
not having seen i mean you name one i
probably haven't seen it so you could
try right now
uh well i'm sure you've seen back to the
future i don't remember it but i did
no kidding i wear jaws
i did but i don't it's not stuck in my
mind because it's not recent i saw the
mages oh okay so does bear watch a lot
of movies do you introduce bear no i try
to keep it really really innocent around
here as
little media as possible but we did oh
great we did just watch like i said the
octopus teacher and we did just watch
clifford the red dog we were crying
and
the other one we watched was bishop the
new one the bishop's wife um with cary
grant
and that is beautiful and um
and we watched bing crosby in
going my way
oh you're cool oh so he's into wow he
sounds like a special kid a great kid
what is a game show pastor present that
you would want to be a contestant on
a game show
do you ever watch um
it sounds like you probably don't watch
a lot of game shows i don't i did when i
was little
yeah
i don't i don't have time for any of
that now yeah yeah it sounds like
by the way when are these movies coming
out um uh the requiem and and last
survivor requiem came out a week ago
requiem would be on demand currently and
same with last survivor it came out on
friday and it will be on demand and then
i have a movie with benicio del toro
and justin timberlake reunion yes coming
out and that but that's not for a bit
but that's called reptile reptile cool
do you drink coffee i'm guessing you
drink
matcha macho matcha to be honest with
you i don't drink any of those things on
a regular basis at all okay um right i
have them as a treat occasionally
tea even tea yeah i mean i'll have
non-caffeinated tea as a
all of those things are just you know
not part of my daily but occasionally
i'll have a green tea or occasionally if
i was out and someone said this is the
best matcha i would want to taste it and
have it but
when i was in paris with my friends
having a ball
i drink coffee to have the experience of
it but it's not part of my daily it
doesn't mean i don't want to put that in
my body it doesn't feel good yeah what
is your if you could learn another
language what would it be well for
goodness sakes i would like to do
spanish all over again because i had
such a bad relationship with it in
school with my teacher um but yeah and
french would be nice too what is your
favorite cereal
there's actually a cereal that i can't
remember the name of and it breaks my
heart because i want it oh the greatest
oh it's a square with it's it's like an
o
oh but it it with little stuff in the
middle no and i don't think it exists
anymore and it's pseudo healthy but it's
not healthy at all
but it was a it was a brand i gotta find
it
honey bunch honey no i
ah god i remember one i loved one that
was also oh it's not a square it was
like a square o
you know a square you know almost yes oh
oh oh crackling oat bran maybe let me
write that down baby crackling oat bran
check it out
i loved franklin o'brien oh man yes it
was but it was hollow in the middle it
was like kind of a scary yes well hollow
yeah that's one
uh if you had to choose a different
first name alicia is a beautiful name
but if you had to choose a different one
what would it be
frankie is what just came from frankie i
love frankie for a girl yeah um if you
had a sandwich named after you what
would be on it the alicia silverstone
sandwich you you're i you're such a
great source of food
well my most favorite treat if you've
come home from a late night or you just
want to be
like in heaven
it's not even a sandwich but it's a
piece of sourdough toast you have to
toast it put miyoko's miyoko's butter on
it
and then you put a big slice of tomatoes
all over that and then a tiny bit of
salt and a tiny bit of pepper if you
don't even need the pepper that's just
bonus and you don't even need the salt
but you could add it
you could add basil but just tomatoes on
toast is what is definitely when bear
asks me mommy what's the meal you want
you know your last meal it's for sure my
last meal i have to it's
oh my god okay well we're almost done
this is perfect uh what is your favorite
tom hanks movie i think forrest gump
because that's the only one that came to
mind
but i also really liked him in
philadelphia that was really good too oh
god yeah i can't remember what else is
there oh there's so many uh splash oh
he's so good in splash and big all of
those zombies yeah oh yeah
that's a dumb question
well would you rather take a time
machine to the past or the future
the past
in the past yeah uh me too are you more
of a talker or a texter when you
communicate
are you a night or morning person
i think both but night night's good just
two things toilet roll over or under
what do you mean over
um would you put the toilet roll over so
it's like this
or under so you have to
pull it i think under probably but i
probably have done it both ways and
never thought about it and i don't even
have it on a thing i just said
okay final thing finish if you would
finish this sentence alicia frankie
silverstone please finish this sentence
life
life is short so
so eat your plants
i love it or life is short so
love
love love
yeah yeah well you are an ambassador for
love and and kindness and spreading um
good things in the world so i i'm so
glad i got to talk to you and and thank
you for all of this and all the
knowledge and
i'll i'll keep going to your site for
more thank you and for reals if you need
help reach out
i will for sure this was fun and uh i
can't wait to see you this was really
cool thank you bye thank you so much
[Music]
so so that just happened so that just
happened there's a crack
i know you i can't that's not it i know
i know it's it's there's a there's a
it's so it's that's closer yeah it's
there's a it's a crack it's it's it's
weird it's a very unique it's not weird
bad it's it's adorable it's like weird
the best it's
kind of weird yeah it but it's so
identifiable you know i mean if i heard
that
anywhere um
i wonder if people here i wonder if
people recognize her a lot just from her
voice i'm sure i'm sure it's so trippy
to hear her voice because
you know for the most part
voices don't change all that much right
over the years you know you like have
your voice after you hit mine has
changed i use puberty i know but you
know what's weird sometimes i watch um
if there's like an early movie i did on
like cheapest creepers will be on your
voice was higher wasn't much yeah it's
kind of like it's like puberty
yeah it was like nasally it's hard for
me to watch those because i immediately
hear like who is that it was it's like
like interviews yeah you've done oh
interviews and i'm so self-conscious and
oh man those are tough but her voice
really does sound the same it does it
does maybe female voices
don't change as much because because
there's i think our i think i was still
going through puberty technique i think
my balls were still
descending
is that what happened it was a slow
decision it was yes there's a long
descent but here we are um yeah but it's
like i i just think oh that cher is
talking i've seen the movie
share horowitz oh many times like so
many times oh whenever it's on tv it's
like oh clueless is on i'll watch the
rest of it
i know
i know like weird and it's also like
that character is so specific in
um
in like the language she used
you guys talked about that a little bit
but the vernacular is is so is so it was
so new to me at the time you know like
california i know uh l.a that kind of
like valley girl that was
brand new i know it was like so hearing
that voice
not use that vernacular and use like our
vernacular now i know and talking about
like very like impressive things like so
thoughtful like
how to generate vitamins and
like vegan diets and and animal welfare
it's like it's so weird to hear that
voice that i know like talking like a
valley girl talking about like shoes and
what outfit she's going to wear this
weekend it's so weird to hear i know
that boys talk about serious things
what's so weird i know i guess cher kind
of did i mean like that was the fun
thing about his children the pizza
i know i know i wonder if people um i
should have asked her this how often
people
assume that about her that i mean we're
talking about that with ryan phillippe
that we assumed he was he had kind of
like he was like an affluenza type guy
yeah similar similar i mean she was
that that is such an indelible
role and so different like you said so
different from who she is i wonder how
that's affected people's perception
never not that like obviously i know
like i'm not a [ __ ] i know how to
separate
performance from an actor but there's
still something about that well can i
posit that like maybe it was so extreme
a character
that people just assume people aren't
dumb i mean like that they know she's
not she doesn't talk like that like as
if she doesn't like use those it was
really an extreme character that's true
that's true maybe people don't think
that what was it based on pygmalion is
it uh
it was my favorite
yeah really but prior to that was
pygmalion yeah i didn't know that i i
think so
but who's her
yeah brittany guide oh a guide is
i don't know if it is no because
wouldn't she need or is it based on jane
austen
oh is it emma emma oh maybe you're right
that sounds familiar i never read emma i
don't think even though i saw the movie
though
i don't even think i saw the movie
because i thought of paltrow was really
pretty because maybe that's why i saw
the movie
you don't believe everything that could
have paltrow and elise and silverstone
are pretty
i
say and they do similar things now isn't
gwyneth paltrow into like yeah
interesting i mean i wonder if they're
friends i wonder i mean i at least yeah
it seems to be more
directed like more like wellness and
nutrition whereas doesn't gwyneth
paltrow have a like a goop goop i know i
know it's it's i know it's like got some
of that in it like nutrition stuff but
like
her focus is wholly on like animal
rights and saving the planet alicia i
mean whereas gwyneth paltrow is a little
bit more
for example doesn't she have a candle
that smells like her vagina
i didn't know that it's true i believe
you isn't that wild
you're hearing this for the first time
yeah it smells like her vagina
i can't confirm that but i couldn't
commit to saying that word out loud
you like breathed it
i failed out yeah
he got bad all i know about goop is that
it's a website that kind of powers
that people like complain about because
she'll be like i've got this like i'm
really reminiscing i'm recommending this
like
uh cold remedy yeah something two
diamonds and it's like three thousand
dollars to make yeah yeah just go to
your largest diamond and scratch off a
portion of it isn't that what it is
people are like i think so really it's
like very rich people it is yeah um
whereas again that so maybe that's an
unfair comparison but they state
were in the sense that they were iconic
you know actual blonde actress yeah
whatever um but her yes her candle
smells like her apparently i thought are
you gonna pivot back no i i really want
you i want this to land with you
i want
just cause i can't believe you're
hearing this for the first time i know
no i just looked at the reason i looked
down was because we both got really loud
and the red thing came up you had been
loud earlier i almost said something too
loud i thought i've had two big cups of
coffee you got really excited about some
what's the least you're sober i know i
know i'm sweating
you look wild um i'm glad this isn't
filmed i'm glad you will be able to walk
for so many reasons
can you believe until you see a
superstar um but what an impressive
person and um god so convicted i know
what she believes i know you know a lot
of people you know a lot of people
i think
have these causes
that they believe in that they talk
about yeah that especially actors and
they're like yeah that sometimes it
feels a little bit like this is like my
cause
she is like she like got so excited
talking about all the different vegan
options yeah talking about clueless she
was like it was like fond memories for
you to talk about but she like got
really excited yeah talking about food
well i wonder if it's because and i i
tried to touch on this i don't know if
i'd articulated it properly if you were
like a good she seems like she was
really ra she was raised well and and
you um value things in life that are
truly important like she seems like that
kind of person and then you get this
like deluge of attention and people are
lauding you and like just celebrating
you and you think like well for this
thing that i did that was
making movies is is
fun
it's like a thing you go and play for a
little bit and like you know it can be
hard long hours blah blah whatever but
like really it's like
it's not that
well yeah like knowing a little bit
about what she's like now and what she's
interested in now and what she promotes
now it came as no surprise when she
talked about as a kid not
seeking fame or
oh i believe her 100 seeking movie star
i know and that she thought you know
doing theater was really loud
it really makes sense yeah she thought
that at the time and that the fame
element of it didn't make her go crazy
you know what's funny as much as like
big of a crush that i had on her when i
was that age when clueless came out and
she was making movies like that like the
babysitter and stuff if i had known like
her substance like who she was as a
person and like what she valued i i it
would have been like even a crazier
crush especially you with the animals
yeah the animals
that really endured oh man you to her
when she got out of the car well yeah
when you said that you've saved turtles
oh yeah yeah i mean i know we would have
really hit it you really would have
although i would have been
physically
way too nervous i was nervous to talk to
girls who were in my grave
speaking of being too nervous that
wondering your stuff is amazing hi fred
savage
and josh saviano
but first of all if you were that age
you wouldn't have had the balls to ask
her out and they both did but they were
all boss both on they were on the hit tv
show
if i had an emmy at 14 maybe i'd ask her
out i know he i love that fred i love
that it went to the father's um fax
machine so he was probably like ah she
gave me a fake number but then i love
that she doesn't know
how paul pfeiffer swooped in and got
it's like it's like
it's like a weird episode of the wonder
years so because i pictured a picture
yeah and then paul pfeiffer ended up
like asking her out sometimes the thing
you want the most is the thing that
you're best
was there ever an episode where they
fought over the same girl there must
have been i'm not remembering there must
have been lisa berlini did they both no
like lisa berlin i don't think so i
think that was just kevin um but also if
you
wonder here's also lisa gerber lisa
gerber she was so funny when she was
like how do you know her name
yes and i wanted to interject and be
like i know how he knows her name he
looked her up to see she was she was
very pretty very pretty yeah i mean
that's a great episode the last great
episode and i had just seen it a couple
weeks ago i got it i got momentarily
subconscious when she was like how do
you know so much about this episode of
the wonder years
this is so funny i've seen it like last
time i've seen that i think that's that
episode i've seen more than the rest of
them for everyone listening if you
haven't seen the episode it's called the
lake if that's the name of the episode
it might be three i think it's three but
it's called the lake and the last
like the whole episode is amazing the
last minute of narration that ends the
episode is like it's hard maybe the most
like profound yeah beautiful things i've
ever seen
when it pulls back in there in the back
of the pickup truck are they talking
about like losing innocence oh i'm
getting like chill i'm getting chills
yeah i am too you don't believe that
chill's thinking about an episode of the
one
but it's like it's incredible
watch that episode yes yeah is that on a
stream like this
um
i don't know it was
yeah anyway it's uh i and then i was
like going on about how great the
episode was and i was like oh i don't
want to
rub it in that you didn't get the part
but
isn't it funny to imagine josh saviano
paul pfeiffer driving around with those
two
beautiful like
killing it kill it killing it i yeah she
loved michael j fox
how crazy was that he got so excited
but also like what a perfect
couple oh my god i mean nothing against
his own real-life relationship no but
like elisa silverstone back then and
michael j fox back then i don't know man
yeah i know i don't know tracy's about
that combo tracy palm is pretty special
of course and like you get to be
like brother-in-law with michael pollan
i said nothing against okay okay
defensive but i know what a couple what
uh because yeah he was is it funny to
imagine um a me a boy like a straight
boy having a but but i think what i have
you know why no yeah boi boy okay not a
boy not a boy what what what is a boy i
don't know um i i think it's but it's
fun to say it is boy skater boy um yeah
like avril lavigne yes hopefully future
friend wow all right back on track all
right
but it's funny to say like it came out
of my mouth so naturally like i had a
crush on him too i know but but i kind
of i guess that's a version of a crush
like winners yeah i remember thinking
boys and boys in class were like cool
and yeah like they had like handsome and
like cool haircuts and like you know
often boys that age are popular for a
reason you know they have a certain sure
i like social sense and they can carry
themselves brian french brian french and
you kind of have a crush on them it
doesn't mean you want to like kiss them
no no in fact but you want to like look
at them you want to look at them you
want to admire them like absorb their
them somehow
yeah he was cool but part of what made
him cool i guess was yeah it's just his
appearance he was like he had like a
cool way of
being like talking and
it was jason bateman too right jason
bateman
yes yeah alicia it's funny that she won
the best villain there's so many things
to talk to her about i hate that we
don't have a lot of time it's so fun to
hear her talk i know and that was like a
trip down memory lane it was she loves
crackling oat bran
i think that's what she was talking
about right definitely
you both have to live correctly to
operate and alicia silverstone
i can't believe that was your reaction
to her candle smelling like her vagina
when i heard that i like what you want
me to do
be more incredulous i was incredulous i
have a less
demonstrative yeah i'm not meaner than
you so i mean i internalized
i was like oh
yeah or like weird i mean well i mean
look like i'm sure it doesn't sound bad
yeah but still ugh like you don't want a
candle to
smell like any body part i don't care
what it is i know but i know but it's
specific i wanted to smell like you know
lilacs or sandals maybe her vagina
smells like sandalwood
you know or maybe there's something
going on whatever just you know what it
is
it's not even like her or her vagina or
anyone's vagina that i'm reacting to
it's more just the idea of doing that
that's like oh it's wild it's just like
weird
it's like weird not in a good way but
you know what i think i may be speaking
at it i think it sells really well i'm
sure
but what do you what portion of the
people who buy gwyneth paltrow's vagina
candle do you think are doing it for
like perverse who want to know oh i
wasn't even thinking that but like as a
joke i was thinking as a joke to give to
a friend as a joke see that's how your
brain works though like
you think that you don't because that's
how you would that's why you would do it
right you were to do it i just saw this
story that you had sent me and also uh
someone else sent me the
the story about the influencer who's
selling her own farts yeah
i would rather have the candle than some
influencers fart
much rat much rather
let's read a letter okay
from imogen sorry by the way imogen to
that's a terrible leader
thank you for writing in by the way
thank you
from imogen what a great name imogen i
like imogen poots poots yeah gay poots
that's what i call her because really
well her middle name is gay oh gay yeah
cool imogen scott chambers
she's british um
imogen what a great name amy
that is a great we should get imogen
poots subject lime skittles continued
and then continued some more wow these
lime skittles are
people are
into this it's gone viral this is a hot
topic
i'm
sure hello i just listened to your
episode with billy zane and loved it you
have such an interesting range of guests
however uh oh however oh
you know that happens a lot like
compliment i guess that's what people
have opinions um and i like constructive
critics yes me too okay here we go you
know both of the constructive criticism
however i should say i've been listening
from day one as i'm a big justin long
fan oh thanks imogen i would call myself
a shorty well then we shall call you
shorty shorty little little shorty billy
saying definitely sounded sexy
he did he does i agree yeah
you know i agree yeah oh yeah you went
that was your that was your coming out
episode is maybe bi
yeah by curious i'm curious i came out
as bicurious yeah um my husband can you
come out as by curious not that that's
something to laugh about no no
no
no very serious yes my curiosity is very
serious serious about vicarious yes
by by seriously
my husband and i love titanic and often
quoted just around her house our
favorite quote being from billy when he
says i put the code on her he says her
like her
and we love doing impressions of it
that's funny i haven't seen it in a
while i shouldn't say her
yeah he does have a
i live in the back to sorry i'm bouncing
around i live in the uk and wanted to
tell you that lime skittles have always
existed here
they have never been apple well not in
my 27 years on this earth so basically
get yourself to the uk if you want some
lime flavored skittles canada too in
canada now bacon flavored spelled with
ew of course the yellow ones are lemons
so eating them together is like a drink
of sprite or something i love lemon and
lime together yeah i know you do moving
on i think they cancel each other moving
on to a cool would you rather it's a
classic film-themed one great this great
letter would you rather have been actors
in the original godfather film members
of the corleone family maybe twins like
justino and cristiano corleone
that's funny
oh man we would not have we would have
been kicked out of the corleone family
we would have been like i mean if if
fredo were there's already already a
fredo
yeah i'm trying to think of a character
who's like more pathetic than fredo i
guess that's who i would be
no you wouldn't be more pathetic than
fredo fredo's real are we talking about
you as a person acting in the movie like
what would you rather act
rather be characters in it'd be fun to
play fredo how did you phrase it she
said would you rather have been actors
in the original godfather that's a
different question yeah okay or or
actors in jaws two more angry people on
the boat drinking rum probably smoking
pot knowing you too
uh
a couple of burners
um
you know what i we were shooting out in
the woods the other day in beautiful
utah and i just smelled this we were in
the middle of nowhere we had to take
snowmobiles together and i just smelled
a waft of pot smoke and i was like whoa
and i
such a boomer i was like wow someone's i
was like
that's yeah i said that and some of the
the cool guys in the crew started
laughing
i was like someone's token some reefer
um
that is a good question i would here's
the thing about being
on the boat in jaws first of all that
shoot was supposed to be like a
nightmare yeah and so a lot of those
great scenes the one about the uss
indianapolis in particular indianapolis
came from uh just not having the shark
ready so they were sitting around like
needing something to shoot yeah and i
would be really intimidated to spend
that much time in close quarters with
robert shaw not
not roy
roy scheider you think is less
intimidating only because i did a play
reading with him he was the sweetest
and um i loved him and
and and i speaking of crushes i thought
he i had a crush on him i thought he was
[ __ ] cool yeah he was cool he was
cool like christopher reeve was cool yes
crush on him but richard dreyfuss
yeah speaking of victories uh richard
dreyfuss um he just seemed like a little
he i i don't think i've been but robert
shaw
man intimidating intimidating so and
obviously marlon brando and [ __ ]
james kahn those guys we have [ __ ]
isn't he james is supposed to be yeah
yeah who knows well yeah especially
difficult yeah i would be intimidated i
would be more intimidated by the
godfather cast i guess you know and
brandon oh yeah i so that i think for
those reasons i would pick jaws even
though and i like i like being on the
water i like being on a boat i don't get
seasick
i know but think about this you would to
be on that boat scene you'd have to be
there for a long time to be in the
godfather film
you you could
shoot anywhere i mean you could you
could be in one of the scenes in italy
i'm sure the accommodations
were more pleasant for the godfather
than jaws but i would make that
sacrifice i think in order to avoid
working with
some of those intimidating actors and i
would rather if i if my character were
to die i'd rather get eaten by a shark
than
shot in a in a mafia hit you would yeah
that'd be cool
that would be awesome um
i'd be terrifying
it's a movie uh that's true
yeah sorry i forgot
what we were talking about wouldn't that
be cool yeah i would be yeah yeah but
like it's different for you because
you've been like turned into a walrus
and like you've been shot and you've
yeah
but i've never died in a movie yeah so i
thought it would be cool to get yeah
killed in jaws i guess it would be
especially the robert shawway where it's
just like
like on your stuff i'd rather be in jaws
okay um great question though yeah
really good uh back to me imogen i took
the liberty of
calling here we were friends now yeah uh
anyway that was what i was thinking
about recently and i'm excited to hear
you two arguing about it and talking
about the merits of these two amazing
films they they are
again like clueless those are movies
that when they're on
way to bring it back um and back to emmy
keep up the good podcasting work some of
my favorite episodes have been steve's
on grandma jody jerry o'connell dave
keckner
and david copperfield oh cool yeah
those ones um
it's funny to go from grandma jody to to
be like oh grandchildren to be to jerry
and be like
jerry o'connell i didn't mean that that
way jerry if you're listening which no
obviously we everyone knows he's the
he's the best friend of the show yeah
i'm currently listening
by the way jerry if you're listening
well he won't tell us if he's listening
no that's part of what makes them jerry
yeah of course um back to imogen buy
from the uk let me know if you're ever
visiting so i can come to your red
carpet event lol yeah because i would
only know well yeah it's like
very funny like you'll ever have a red
carpet event
your days of walking the red carpet are
over
um has been
anyway
thank you imogen i didn't mean to
undercut your very sweet letter um
with the self-deprecating comment uh
imogen and then she says looking forward
to hearing how you pronounce my name as
it's so weird but it's in a shakespeare
play if that helps imogen twelfth night
uh imagine so i don't think that's in
twelfth night xoxo
what's shakespeare just look up
shakespeare and magenta imogen
oh man shakespeare
cymbeline
oh similar you know i've never read
you know i've never heard of it oh no
yeah i think it's one of the history
plays i
symboline uh
i wonder if there's anyone named
cymbeline that's a pretty name yeah as
is imogen yeah if you guys would like to
write into the show our email addresses
life is short at wondery.com
and um and speaking of pretty names
thank you alicia yes man uh it's hard to
ask someone with a beautiful name like
that if what other name they'd want i
know what what did she say
frankie frankie yeah i love that name
too yes
frankie for a girl uh anyway thank you
alicia and check out her new podcast
yes and all the new movies and um you
know the real heel the real name of it
so people can find the real heel and
check out her new products they're great
as you can hear
they're called my kind organics and um
obviously uh non-gmo verified like we
talked about uh such good stuff so thank
you alicia for those and um for for
being so so thanks for all your great
work yeah thanks for making us so happy
throughout our lives thanks for being an
icon uh we'll talk to you next week
thanks guys
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
yeah life is short is hosted by me
justin long it is co-hosted and produced
by you christian law it's also produced
by megan v monaco and katie allen and
senior producers michelle miesh lans
audio engineer sergio enriquez the man
who is the executive producer is
marshall louis and um the company that
we do it for is laundry
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
do
[Music]
[Music]
god
you